Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P, our friend, the egg man called in.
The egg man, as you may know, is a Jewish
gentleman from a rural New York state.
He is reporting an anti-Semitic incident as
he was considering buying a used car.
Let's listen to the egg man story.
Speaker 5: Hi, Dave.
I test drove a car that I was going to buy
with a private seller during the test drive.
The guy made anti-Semitic comments and anti
LGBTQ comments really disgusting.
When we finished the test drive, I told him
in the Wegmans parking lot to his face the
things he said were vile and disgusting, and
I would never buy a car from him.
He just stared at me, said nothing.
I drove away.
He pulled up next to me, the traffic light
spit in my face in the window.
Curse me out.
Anti Semitic stuff, anti LGBTQ yelled at me,
a bunch of spit in my window and kind of chased
him down by.
The dude was very scared He drove over curb
evaded me.
That was definitely a hate crime right there.
Should I call the police and report it?
I do have his actual name from Facebook Marketplace.
Or should I just blow it off?
Because that's how things are in western New
York.
Shalom.
Speaker 1: Well, shalom to the egg, man.
So here's my thought on this.
I am not a lawyer, nor a police officer.
The.
I see two possible crimes here.
Spitting, I guess the.
That was one hell of a loogie spitting through
out his window and into the egg man's window.
That's.
That's a lot.
But that seems like that would be a crime.
And then I don't know if this the guy driving
over the curb in an erratic attempt to get
away from the egg.
That maybe is a crime.
I don't know if the egg man was chasing this
guy in his car.
It's possible the egg man committed some crime.
I don't.
I don't know about that.
So.
Listen, I'm going to leave this one to the
audience.
Should the egg man report this to the police
and let them handle it or not?
I want to hear from you.
Leave a comment on YouTube.
Maybe make a post on the subreddit.
People can have a discussion.
That is a hell of a situation.
Hell of a situation.
I've been in a lot of anti-Semitic situations,
but none.
None quite like that.
But glad that the egg man is safe.
On today's bonus show.
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody.
Speaker 2: Else that makes money to fund themselves
is back.
Speaker 1: Cornell West has announced that
he is running for president under the People's
Party umbrella, a party that is not on the
ballot.
They have no ballot access in any state will
be very interesting discussion on the bonus
show.
I'm sure YouTube has altered its policy to
allow false claims about past US presidential
elections.
What does this mean and do they really mean
it?
And lastly, Robert Hanssen, arguably the most
damaging FBI spy in history, has been found
dead in his prison cell.
I know quite a bit about Robert Hanssen.
We actually interviewed on this program the
FBI agent who was tasked with catching Robert
Hanssen, played by Ryan Phillippe, eventually
in the movie adaptation of that story.
A very interesting situation, an incredible
story.
And we will discuss it on today's bonus show.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.
It's very cheap, folks, and it's our number
one source of funding.
I hope to see you on the bonus show in a few.